members
uh we meet tonight under very sad
circumstances
and following the london bridge protocol
that's been expressed to me and in view
of the lateness of the
uh
information about the queen's
death
um
i intend to ask you to stand for a
two-minute silence members would you
please stand
it's time
so
thank you members please be seated
the protocol says
that we have a two minute silence and
then we
have recollections of the queen
my recollections of the queen
is
um i have uh met her or
i have been introduced to her whatever
the protocol is
i've had the pleasure
of
um
being present and having lunch in her
presence when she visited mullen
i believe for the second time in her
reign
first time was in the 1971
council and nan would correct me if i'm
wrong
and i would just like to share those
memories with you there may be some of
you
that were in mauldin on her visit
uh and
it was a
a moving experience then
and it's a terribly moving moment now
uh
is there any other member that wishes to
have
any thoughts
counselor channel
thank you chairman
yes i was one of the members present
when her majesty visited malden
and it was a very humbling experience
but i think what impressed me the most
was
we were given instructions to say you
don't approach her majesty
um you don't sort of hurt you you don't
speak to her and her majesty came into
the malden town council offices
and we were all standing there in a
horseshoe
and her majesty took the time to speak
to every one of us
and asked questions
sorry i find this very upsetting thank
you
and thank you leader
does any other member wish to speak
right
then i'm sure
that
her majesty and her family are in our
thoughts and prayers
and having said that i now adjourn the
meeting
sign or die
you